si yo llegara un día a tu casa y te
preguntará cuál es el nombre de esta
molécula tú lo primero que me dirías es
sal aquí tenemos un enlace doble por lo
cual la terminación de esta molécula va
a ser que no y por otro lado tenemos
aquí una cadena de 1 2 3 4 carbonos
entonces vamos a tener por allí el
prefijo but de 4 carbono y además el
doble enlace sin importar como en
números a los carbonos empieza en el
segundo carbono entonces el nombre de
esta molécula tiene que ser
but the que son 4 carbonos 2 de que el
doble enlace empieza en el segundo
carbono y el no de que tenemos un doble
enlace y yo te diría que esto está muy
bien que de acuerdo a lo que hemos visto
en estos vídeos este es el nombre de
esta molécula pero yo te quiero
preguntar qué hay de esta otra molécula
tenemos por aquí un doble enlace
dos grupos metidos y los hidrógenos cuál
es el nombre de esta otra molécula y
bueno por aquí tenemos un enlace doble
por lo que esta molécula es un al que no
y tiene 1 2 3
4 carbonos y sin importar como
enumeramos estos carbonos el enlace
doble empieza en el segundo carbono así
es que esta molécula se llama wood 2
cierto
sin embargo estas dos moléculas son
fundamentalmente distintas o sea esta
molécula tiene este doble enlace que si
recuerdan aquí es un enlace sigma y
luego otro enlace pi que evita que la
molécula puede rotar a lo largo de este
enlace entonces esta molécula no puede
rotar de esta conformación a esta otra
conformación por lo que realmente son
con formaciones distintas ok
estas dos moléculas son diferentes
y químicamente van a tener distintos
comportamientos entonces no podemos
estarlo llamando de la misma forma
ahora para nombrar a estas dos moléculas
de forma distinta tenemos dos
convenciones una que es más simple pero
que solo sirve cuando tenemos únicamente
un grupo funcional por cada carbono del
doble enlace y otra que es más
complicada y que vamos a ver con todo
detalle en los próximos vídeos entonces
estamos circulando los grupos metidos
ahora si nos fijamos en esta molécula
los grupos metilo están como que
separados están del otro lado de la
cadena y en esta molécula los grupos
están del mismo lado entonces en el
primer sistema de nomenclatura que es el
más sencillo a esta conformación a esta
molécula le llamamos trans
que viene del latín que significa más
allá que pues también está relacionado
con esto de que estos dos grupos metilo
se estén separados así es que esta
molécula se llama trans wood 2n bueno y
en el segundo sistema de nomenclatura lo
que usamos es la palabra en alemán que
significa separados que es antigua pero
disculpen mi pronunciación en alemán
bueno en lugar de escribir toda la
palabra lo que hacemos es escribir una y
entre paréntesis y después
ruth 2
ok esta es de en qué que qué significa
separados en alemán ahora este sistema
de nomenclatura que toma la de enrique
del alemán que bueno literalmente lo que
significa es
posición
este sistema de nomenclatura es el que
se usa normalmente porque se puede
extender a moléculas en las que tenemos
más de un grupo funcional en cada uno de
los carbonos y bueno esta molécula con
el primer sistema de notación que
utiliza las palabras del latín se llama
sis wood 12 no ok si es en el latín
significa que están juntos o si usamos
el segundo sistema de nomenclatura
ponemos entre paréntesis una zeta y
después el butt
21 gay z para denotar la palabra en
alemán sus amén
que literalmente significa juntos juntos
entonces estamos diciendo en alemán
juntos but 12 no y a esta molécula en
alemán lo estamos llamando en oposición
but 12 no porque estos grupos metidos
están en oposición y estos grupos metilo
se están juntos en los próximos vídeos
vamos a ver más ejemplos para ver cuando
ponemos una d en que creen o una seta de
sus a mente pero ahorita en este vídeo
era muy importante también ver la
anotación trans y sí que sepas que estos
dos nombres significan exactamente la
misma molécula porque cuando tenemos
moléculas simples como éstas a veces se
utiliza mucho esta anotación de trans y
sis